- You know I'm concerned a
little bit with the culture of
celebrating the fundraise.
My dad taught me that when
you borrow money it's
the worst day of your life.
(xylophone music)
Starting my morning
with a talk at Twitter
which is a lot of fun.
Often talk how that's my
first love even though I was on
YouTube before that.
It was Twitter that really
kind of changed the course of my
career in a lot of ways.
Obviously, I've got my
concerns on where
Twitter is at this day and age.
But optimistic with Jack
back in the fold and
we'll see what he's up to.
Excited to see Joel,
major executive there.
Good to see a man.
- How you doing?
- [DRock] Good, how are you?
- Old friend. Big fan.
I'm a big fan of Joel.
It should be a good morning
and I'm excited to see how goes.
- We have this coffee bar.
- This is gorgeous.
- We could get coffee.
Maybe we should do that.
(siren wailing)
- [DRock] What's wrong?
- [Joel] Make a run for it.
- The biggest thing that I think
went wrong in my opinion is just
no product changes forever.
- Forever, yeah.
- This is really
fucking unbelievable.
Yeah. This is unbelievable.
I think it can help.
- I know.
- I truly feel like no joke
what did we just,
listen this is important.
I did it on Snapchat.
Oh no, I did to the
camera for my vlog today.
Often talk about how that's
my first love, I talked about
coming here and I said
Twitter's my first love.
- [Joel] Yeah.
- But I do think,
and I'll say this later,
I think there's a
firehose problem.
I'm a believer that an algori,
but there's video me in 2011
saying Twitter need to do this.
People on the false sense
of reaching mass audience in
Twitter right now because of
this enormous firehose of data.
When you put out a tweet not
everyone is going to see it,
so that to you and it's up to
Twitter to figure out how to
break through the noise.
If I was a product person all
the way through and through
that's the opportunity.
- [Joel] Build another.
- America, excuse me, the
world needs a water cooler.
You can't use Facebook,
Instagram and Snapchat
during the NBA finals.
- [Joel] You just can't.
- You just can't.
Not the way Twitter works.
I thought yesterday was
a super interesting day in
the history of social media.
Yesterday, Snapchat made a huge
change, Instagram went from
15 seconds to a minute on their
video for everybody not just
advertisers and you
guys created captions
on top of your pictures.
This is cool. This is important.
Three of the five major,
six major platforms all had
significant changes I think we
need to see a lot more of that.
- [Joel] I'm going to open
questions in one second.
- Come sit here.
DRock, you're going to
have to pick up your camera.
Sorry buddy. Eat it.
Come on in, guys.
Get in.
They block the pathway.
What Mark has done better than
anybody, and I met Mark in 2008
and I was a crazy wine guy and
Mark asked me to speak and off
of one speech we became friends
for a very long period of time
during the early days of
Facebook because we agreed on
consumer behavior and the
one North Star, attention.
There's only one
thing, attention.
You can monetize your ads
when you have the attention.
When you have the number one
show on television and you have
the attention, you make money.
That's just the way it is.
That's what we agreed on even
way back then and that's why he
bought Instagram in 500 days and
that's why he offered $3 Billion
18 months ago for Snapchat.
Everyone's confused
where they'd come from.
He understood that and offered
to $3 billion for it 18 months
ago because he understands
attention's the asset and
I think that's the thing that
has been waning. I've seen it.
Listen, as a user every day
for 9 1/2 years, every day.
I know that eight years ago if I
said follow my friend Joel he's
awesome 2,000 people would do
that when I had 7,000 followers
and now 37 will do that when
I have 1.2 million followers.
That's going to be a
problem for people.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
(applause)
Good talk at Twitter.
Amazing executives, great team
there I'm a big believer that
the hyperbole of Twitter is dead
is well overstated however I've
been talking about it since 2011
and '12 so I believe that there's
a vulnerability there's a
massive decline of attention you
guys know I care
about attention.
But much like a network when
they pick two or three great
shows that bring back the
network like ABC did with "Lost"
or CBS with "Big Bang Theory"
and "Two and a Half Men" or
like NBC did with "Seinfeld"
and "Friends" years ago.
Networks have shows
to revive them,
I think products have
features that can revive them.
And comms, communication to
the world about how they're
different and evolve, it'll be
interesting to see if
Twitter can pull
off a revival.
(relaxed easy listening music)
- [Man on phone] Sup man?
Watching your DailyVees,
I have one question, how do
you get other businessmen
to notice you and your--?
- Getting other business men and
women to notice you is easy when
you actually
build big businesses.
I don't worry about
getting them to notice me
I just go and
fucking execute.
Caroline's also working on
custom pop-ups so that might be
able to help us but then again
if we have too many pop-ups
competing with each
other, right, so.
- Real quick, stay in touch
with me here is replicated here.
- Mhmmm.
- Could be an
interesting debate?
- Hi, Sean Lyons.
- Hey, Gary.
- I'm sorry I'm overdressed.
- Dude. You look great.
You look absolutely great.
You're not overdressed.
- [Both] Hi, nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I'm well and yourself?
- Good.
The vlog. Yeah, the vlog.
Thank you so much.
We cut stuff of all the time.
If you don't want anything--
- It's good.
- If you want to do B-roll
because it's fun to see it on
the show then we'll do that.
- So are going to
be on your show?
- I do a daily vlog
multiple times a week--
- Yes.
- where this meeting
clearly will not be.
- Okay.
- But B-roll throughout
the day or potentially not.
That's totally up to you guys.
Talk about Giants a lot.
New York Giants, big Giants fan.
No, not that.
I'm wearing my
Jets sneakers today.
I do like the Yankees but the
Yankees had won in my life so
that means that I
don't like them anymore.
- Oh really?
You always root
for the underdog?
- I don't shoot for any underdog
but once my teams win,
I kind of check out.
So the Rangers, yeah, the
Rangers and Yankees are gone.
- [Man] What happens if
the Jets start winning?
- [Gary] Well they
have to win a Super Bowl.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Let's start with that.
I don't know.
That's literally one
of the most popular
conversations in my family.
- Then you'll
become a Bills fan?
- Definitely not.
- Not going to follow Rex?
- No, I hate him.
I only like the
people on my team.
- Yeah.
- The second they
switch, they're out.
I would become the biggest
Knicks fan in the world.
They'd be last one.
- So the reason why I know you
video tape is a good friend of
mine met with you probably three
or four weeks ago Todd Sawyer.
- Yes.
- "Ferraris and Watches"
- Yes. That was a good episode.
- I look out my back
window and I look at his house.
- So what is that Mendon?
- Randolph.
- Yeah. Close enough.
- That's very cool.
That's awesome. Nice guy.
- He was pretty jazzed after--
(slow paced trance music)
- Trucking along on my day.
Just had a bunch of
employee meetings
had a potential client meeting,
couple of phone calls.
Brand workshop.
Just typical operation stuff.
No fancy interviews, no TV,
no just operating like a
CEO of a 650 person company.
Super boring.
Super fun to catch
up with my team.
I probably don't do
those meetings often enough.
But just good to recap with
them on what were doing with the
brand where we're putting out
the content, what the strategies
are as we now transition off of
right hook mode for the book we
go into a two-year
cycle of straight jabs.
So where can I produce the
best and most valuable content.
Which channels should I
focus on to increase
distribution to
create awareness?
The other this I
want to be smart.
I don't think last
night's video was smart.
Let me explain why.
I want to use these meetings
to get more IP exchange.
We just had a 5 million organic
video that had the same visual,
I promise you one of things that
hurt today's video was people
thought it was the same one.
If you're talking into a
room when nobody is you lose.
That would become a
much bigger focus point.
Hello India.
- Hi.
- What are you doing here?
- I'm coming with you.
- 'Cause you're
excited about this?
- [India] I'm super excited.
- [Em] I'm coming too.
- I know you're excited.
No DRock.
(India and Em laughing)
I'm in the comments.
I'm in my zone.
Why don't you film that?
- [DRock] I am.
I'm just wondering
where we're going?
You know?
- We're going to
Huffington Post.
Right Em?
- Yes.
Hey.
- [Man] How are you?
- How are you?
- [Man] Thanks for coming down.
- [Gary] Thanks for having me.
- Hey Gary, nice to meet you.
Lauren.
- I'm going to have you sort of
switch cameras to the steady and
we're just going to walk out
here and we can show you the
route where we want to go.
- Let's do it.
- Gary, seriously,
I'm such a huge fan.
- Thank you, brother.
What is your name?
- I'm so exited to see you.
Vincent.
- Vincent.
- I'm from France.
- Thank you so much
that if he so happy.
- So glad to see you.
- No.
- I didn't know
you're coming in.
- Well, thank you so much.
- Thank you.
You want take a picture?
- Yeah, sure.
- Let's do it.
- That'd be awesome.
- Yeah.
Oh my gosh. Thank you.
- Listen, thanks
for saying hello.
- Thank you, Gary.
- Thank you for
those kind words.
I will.
- Thank you.
- Take care, brother, thank you.
You see before it wasn't
practical to actually quit your
job and go start a flower shop
or go start something about the
Rolling Stones or something
here, there or everywhere.
It's now, for the first time
ever, practical to go and start
a blog or a video blog or a
podcast around Alf or
the Smurfs or college football.
This is real. You can
make money. It's 2016.
- One more time, Gary.
Done.
- Wait one more.
Go ahead.
- Beautiful.
- Literally, that's the most
takes I've ever taken.
DRock, most takes
I've ever done.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Pleasure.
- Gary, thanks so much.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm a real New Yorker.
Those three not so much.
Scared to cross.
Alright, safety pants.
Let's go safety pants.
- [India] Gary, do you
want to have a team?
- This is unbelievable content.
- [India] What?
- Besides the health and
wellness of people that I admire
and adore and most importantly
love, wasting time is the
thing I'm most scared of.
Do you have any interest
in doing, you talked about,
dirty little secret of the
entrepreneur world?
Like mental health, depression
and that sort of thing.
Do you want to talk
about that at all?
- Yeah, I think I do.
I do. I do.
And here's what I
want to frame it.
Again ask questions or
frame it or take this
for what it's worth.
The overpromise of what
success looks like is
what's causing people to lose.
No different than the way
teenage girls who are pounded
with what pretty is and then
when it's not achievable,
it leads to bad behavior
like being bulimic
or really being
down on yourself.
There's exactly the same
thing happening right now in
entrepreneurship which is if
you don't build a $10 million
business then you're a loser.
Or the other thing that I've
railed on and you can pull of
the old Bloomberg clip.
I'm concerned a little
bit with the culture of
celebrating the fundraise.
My dad taught me that
when you borrow money
it's the worst day
of your life.
So I'm very interested in the
entrepreneurs, we didn't clap
for Red Rover because it didn't
raise $6 trillion but I was
sitting here like good stuff.
I just filtered myself.
(audience laughter)
What I'm looking for is
people that are not
caught up in the excitement.
Even though I'm a
hype man myself,
I like the practicality
of it all.
People that understand how to
turn a profit I mean at the end
of the day this is still
business right so I'm looking
for real practical knowledge of
how to actually make money
not necessarily raise it.
Success is raising the value of
your company instead of actually
building a company which is
why nobodys building companies,
they're building financial
arbitrage machines
which I talk a lot about.
If the bottom 1%, if the bottom
of the top 1% is $400,000 a year
because of the
clarification I've gotten, right?
Well then that's unbelievable.
If you take home $400,000 a year
as an entrepreneur and so here
we go how close are
you one to the top 1%?
And you can link to this it's
CNN/calculator/PF/income-rank.
Here we go.
If you make $100,000
you're in the top 24%.
$155,000 a year means in
your in the top 10% earners.
You've hit the level of top 10%.
I think that needs, there's
a lot of people that can use
YouTube and Facebook and Twitter
and WordPress I think there's a
lot of people right now that
can build a design firm I keep
pounding my designers
here of Snapchat filters.
They'll go away but you can
build $155,000 year business one
person shop on
Snapchat filters right now.
And then you're in the top
10% earners and I don't think
somebody who makes $155,000 as
their income, post expenses which
a la if you're in the service
business, sitting in your house,
I don't think they
feel like they're in
the top 10% in America.
And that's why were leading to
depression and even,
in extreme cases, suicide which
makes me upset which is
why I'm willing to become
unpopular and
have this conversation because
I think it's my responsibility
as a fan of entrepreneurship to
reframe the conversation
of what success looks like.
And making a million-dollar year
as an entrepreneur is,
in real data form,
just not real.
The reason the good part is
it's true which is why I'm
comfortable with that I believe
is my responsibility and every
other purebred entrepreneur to
give back to entrepreneurship
and I think reframing the
conversation of success and
within it because I do think
entrepreneurship success
is in everybody cards.
When I say not everybody's an
entrepreneur and people have
entrepreneurial tendencies
what I mean is not everybody is
supposed to build a
billion-dollar company.
There's a lot of people that can
have entrepreneurial tendencies
that bring them top 1%
happiness financially.
Super great day.
Got a lot accomplished.
Was fun to be at HuffPo.
Was fun to be at Vayner.
Was fun to be at Twitter.
Fun to be with AJ.
It was fun. I love the game.
Day in and day out.
I love the game.
See you at 5:30 in the morning.
Yep.
(light piano music)